As you go through this course, and when you're
analyzing data on your own, we want you to
keep the following in mind. Always be curious and
skeptical when you're taking a look at data. Nate Silver
a statistician noted for his work in baseball and
in politics, captured the sentiment as well. He said, People
should be more skeptical when they see numbers. They
should be willing to play around with the data themselves.
Exploratory data analysis is one of the best tools that we
have for playing with the data. For letting the data speak
really directly. When conducting an exploratory data analysis. We want to
test our intuitions about the data set and develop new intuitions.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
When you're going through this course and analyzing the data sets that we're
going to take a look at. We want you to be excited to play
with the data. But we also want you to be open to detecting
oddities in the data. Especially through
the visualizations and summaries that you produce.